das ist kein videospiel das sind echte
pistolen jeder kann sie kaufen oder
selbst herstellen schöne neue waffen
welt das baby hier kostet euch gerade
mal 150 dollar
ghost ganz geister waffen zum selbst
bauen ohne seriennummer ohne
waffenschein
egal ob kleinkrimineller oder terrorist
jeder kann sich die benötigten teile
besorgen und innerhalb von einer halben
stunde zusammenbauen
die us-regierung will sie gerne
verbieten denn immer wieder werden mit
ghost ganz unschuldige ermordet sowie im
juni 2013
über zuschauer guten tag ein amokläufer
hat im kalifornischen santa monica vier
menschen erschossen und mehrere verletzt
der mann hatte an verschiedenen orten in
der stadt wahllos um sich gefeuert am
ende waren es sechs tote der braafheid
ist die einzige die damals angeschossen
wurde und überlebt hat die heute
59-jährige bei hier mit ihrem auto
unterwegs plötzlich sah sie einen mann
mit sturmgewehr er sah mich an und
eröffnete das feuer erzielte auf meine
windschutzscheibe mein auto kam etwa
hier zum stehen eine kugel traf mich in
die linke schulter durch die wucht wurde
ich auf den beifahrersitz geschleudert
ich erinnere mich noch wie meine hand
über die fußmatte streift dann trafen
mich zwei kugeln hier und eine weitere
zerfetzte mein ohr und ich dachte nur
bitte bitte lass sie nicht merken dass
ich noch lebe hoffentlich bringt er es
nicht zu ende
kein tag vergeht an dem nicht daran
denken muss auch weil der mann der sie
töten wollte eigentlich gar keine waffe
hätte besitzen dürfen
2011 wollte er eine kaufen und bestand
wegen psychischer probleme den
hintergrund check nicht also
recherchierte er online fand eine
anleitung bestellte die teile steckte
sie zusammen fertig war die kost gang
debra macht es angst dass das so einfach
geht in einem land dessen waffen hunger
weiter steigt im letzten jahr wurden in
den usa knapp
21.000 menschen durch schusswaffen
getötet so viele wie nie zuvor
wir haben so viele proteste auf den
straßen und andere dinge also denken
mehr und mehr amerikaner dass sie eine
waffe brauchen das erklärt auch die
steigenden zahlen bei erstkäufern die
leute wollen sie zu hause haben und sich
schützen zu können und auch kurs ganz
werden wir in zukunft häufiger sehen
weil wir uns alle daran gewöhnt haben
dinge im internet zu bestellen
amerika rüstet auf das macht es auch für
die polizei schwieriger im hauptquartier
der polizei von los angeles dem
npd-treffen wir captain sparrow eröffnet
für uns die asservatenkammer zeigt uns
eine auswahl an ghost ganz im letzten
jahr haben er und sein team rund
1600 konfisziert etwa dreimal so viele
wie im vorjahr
wir müssen dringend die anzahl der
waffen in den straßen reduzieren es sind
einfach zu viele umso mehr aufgerüstet
wird umso mehr verbrechen gibt es
der captain erklärt uns dass nicht nur
der waffen boom an sich ein problem ist
sondern auch der umstand dass ghost ganz
viel leichter in die falschen hände
geraten als offiziell verkaufte waffen
[Musik]
so ganz kann sich jeder besorgen ein
verurteilter straftäter jemand der
psychische probleme hat oder ein
gangmitglied also genau die leute von
denen wir auf keinen fall wollen dass
sie an waffen gelangen aber sie können
auf diesem wege einfach die nötigen
checks
in austin/texas treffe ich einen mann
der mit ghost ganz großes business macht
cody ist ghost ghana der ersten stunde
größter händler der welt ethischer
bedenken kennt er nicht und glaubt fest
sein land der freiheit hat auf seine
idee gewartet
ich mache mir keine gedanken wird der
sicherheit der gesellschaft darum geht
es nicht in amerika geht es darum wie
man größtmögliche freiheit erreichen
kann und darum wie man sich selbst und
sein eigentum am besten beschützen kann
eine waffe kann da sehr hilfreich sein
in rund drei monaten tritt ein erlass
des us-präsidenten in kraft nach dem
künftig auch große anteile seriennummern
haben müssen außerdem sollen verkäufer
sicherstellen dass käufer eine waffe
besitzen dürfen bodies geschäfte wird
das nicht durchkreuzen seiner
verkaufsschlager sind nämlich nicht mehr
die teile selbst sondern fräsmaschinen
die können aus einem stück plastik oder
metall alles formen jeder soll sich
seine waffe zu hause selbst entwerfen
können das ist sein traum von einer
freien gesellschaft
ich habe mir den entwurf angesehen und
kann nur sagen das kurbelt mein business
sogar noch weiter
das sollte den eine lektion
in großen staaten und demokratien ist es
eben manchmal so du möchtest etwas
bestimmtes erreichen und denkst zu
wissen wie aber in wirklichkeit machst
du alles noch viel schlimmer der reis
das gegenteil dessen was du möchtest
cody weiß seine waffen marke eigenbau
funktionieren reibungslos
mit einem ähnlichen gewehr hat der
amokläufer von santa monica sechs
menschen erschossen das ist cody egal
mir geht es nicht darum brücken zu den
kritikern zu bauen ich will dass es so
einfach wird eine waffe zu bekommen dass
es sinnlos wird uns stoppen zu wollen
die geplante verschärfung der
waffengesetze wird die nicht aufhalten
und so kämpft er weiter für seine idee
der freiheit eine gesellschaft in der
jeder seinen finger am abzug hatte